[Music]
so
today i'm doing this talk with you
called how to think about sex
um and it is quite a strange
way for me to to think about it because
i don't want to come across as
instructing you this is how you must
think about sex because
precisely my point is that there isn't a
particular way
um of thinking about sex this is a way
of subverting or
changing the dominant or conventional
way
of thinking about sex um so why am i so
interested in this
um so it's one of those things where
whereby i'm so
completely fascinated um by philosophy
um and also completely fascinated by sex
um and i want to understand so i'm
really drawn um
to to understanding about sexuality
um and and i have this very love-hate
relationship with philosophy
which i think will really come through
here um i think there's good reason
for it um so the first
sort of question that comes to mind when
i think about
thinking and sex is
why are is why are the rules and why is
the basis
for the rules when thinking about sex
so rigid and this is such a
it's a solid body of thought which we
try and apply to something
that is so fluid something so fluid like
a human sexuality something so bodily
and we're trying to apply this this text
um and this big canon of thought that is
made up of
of all these books and and thinking and
logic and we're trying to apply that to
something
that that's that's not that it's
something very bodily and unpredictable
so i'm really interested in in how to
bring these
things together and as and what has
happened when we have
tried to bring these things together
first of all i just want to talk about
where philosophy fits in the general
kind of framework when thinking
about sex so why philosophy why have i
chosen philosophy
to put with sex given that i've just
pointed to a real mismatch
in the two things so there are various
places from which rules come from
so we've got politics and society and
that's something we're quite accustomed
to turning to but we want to
understand sexuality or identities
how these identities are contested
all the battles that go on in relation
to gender politics sexuality and so on
we also have religion which is a big
factor
when we come to talk about um society
and politics because of course the rules
and so on
uh in relation to various religions feed
into society and politics
and all of this is kind of i would say
bound together by law as well so all of
these things influence the law so what
is right
and what is wrong particularly when we
come to thinking about sex
and this in turn then leads to
how we consider ethics in sexuality
so how and what we are allowed to do
um how we are allowed to feel who we're
allowed to have sex with who we're not
allowed to have sex with
i would like to do sort of um quotes
here as in
isn't allowed as in what does the law
say what does what does the political
situation say what does society say
about this and so these are various
things that we can turn to
and what i would suggest is that
the philosophy underpins all of these
things
it's particular ways of thinking and
values that we hold out as being
important and these values
they tend to feed into that they don't
just exist in this textual format in all
these books
that we see in libraries or on our
bookshelves it's not just in volumes of
philosophy
and it's not just in law books and so on
where these rules exist
but we embody them so not only do we
read them
we hear about them on the news on the
radio whatever
we're exposed to them as we're growing
up um other people
are also exposed to them so we're
socialized into
into a particular set of rules and so we
embody them they they become part of the
way that we move
and as it relates to sexuality so
bringing this back to how this impacts
our sexuality and our desire is that
certain things like for instance the
presumption
of heterosexuality um there's
presumptions about
monogamy um ways in which we think
desires are allowed and not allowed so
kink and bdsm masturbation all of these
things
that people might think of as taboo
or might not feel like they fit within
these things
so it has this impact of making us think
that certain things are allowed and
certain things are not
it's something that feeds through the
media as well it's all of these messages
that we get are all underpinned
by a certain philosophical way of
thinking
so we've got the way that our bodies
then move and then we've got
the foundation of all of that so kind of
the architecture of all that the
architecture of the rules
and so going back to that so it doesn't
come out of the sky
it's written it's also embodied
um so when we think about philosophy we
we tend to think about
i expect when you think about philosophy
you think of philosophers so who some of
these philosophers might be
so we might start with aristotle who is
widely known as the
as the grandfather of philosophy sort of
um one of philosophy's fathers
um and perhaps one of the biggest
figures in philosophy
but he's not just alone so he's perhaps
at the very start we have a long lineage
that builds up the canon of what we
understand as being
western philosophy philosophy aristotle
can't um all these big names that we
think of when we think
philosophy so what i'm trying to say
here
is that philosophy kind of feeds its way
into
um the political and societal
um environment that we live in
and it informs what our ethical codes
are in relation to one another
so there's a whole corpus if you like of
philosophy it's a whole body
that that moves um but also that we are
interconnected with
and you might think well okay that's
great i mean whatever there's a
relationship between philosophy and
sexuality there's a relationship between
philosophy
um and politics and society so what who
cares
it's important because of the way it
informs our judgments about sexuality
so if we think about sexuality
as that which is found our ways of
thinking
we can think about sexuality as
informing what we
think of as morality
and once we understand what we think of
as morality
this becomes then a standard um
it's not just a standard by which we
judge others so if we
accept morality as being important um
and something that is either depending
on your philosophical school it might be
something that comes from god
it might be something that we all accept
as human beings as being
some kind of moral consensus which
obviously it isn't
because we all have different ideas of
what morality is
or perhaps there's a philosophical
school of thought that says well there's
actually
certain key aspects of morality that we
can all agree on as human beings
um but then those are also contested
right
or does it come from somewhere else or
is it just something that we arrive at
throughout our daily lives and think
okay well this seems to be the right
moral code for you through which to live
which is all very well it sounds kind of
quite neat
but then if we think about sexuality
which is something
that we're all so different um we have
so many different desires
um so many different identities so many
different experiences each
person is completely individual
completely unique in this respect
so how can we possibly say that some
moral objective standard can apply to us
all
and yet philosophically that's supported
so the problem with morality then is
that we that we then have judgment that
comes after that
so if we say that the standard is this
then obviously logically
um and it tends to be human thing to say
well this person
has infringed this part of the moral
code so our judgment is that their
identity their desire
is wrong it is outside of what we accept
as being allowed so
these kind of rules what could they be
so in relation to sexuality this might
be about
fidelity and monogamy so it's about okay
well
if you're with some one person you can't
desire somebody else and
this is something that if we look back
into the lineage of philosophy and
religion we can see this rule
feeding throughout so it's about desire
it's also about
when we have sex who we have sex with um
and through these kind of judgments what
happens
is that through the authority of these
judgments
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you